ce serait l'ouragan le plus puissant à
avoir touché terre à ce jour le bilan
s'élève à plus de 5000 morts et dix
mille blessés plus de la moitié des
récoltes ont été détruites des routes
sont impraticables des ponts détruits au
moins 60% des 1400 résidents sont
maintenant sans abri s'est réfugié
climatique s'ajoute à tous ceux qui
fuient les guerres et les persécutions
et n'ont jamais été aussi nombreux quand
on parle de réfugiés climatiques
en général on veut désigner toutes les
personnes qui sont obligés de migrer à
cause des impacts du changement
climatique
qu'il s'agisse d'un pacte très brutaux
comme des inondations des sécheresses ou
des ouragans ou alors des impacts plus
lent et progressif notamment la hausse
du niveau des mers ou la dégradation des
sols il est possible de distinguer trois
grandes régions du monde où les
populations sont particulièrement
affectés aujourd'hui déjà par les
impacts du changement climatique et cela
provoque des migrations parfois
importants il s'agit bien sûr de
l'afrique subsaharienne où les gens sont
touchés à la fois par des variations
température et de pluviométrie et par la
dégradation des sols et la sécheresse
il s'agit de l'asie du sud et du sud-est
qui est la région du monde la plus
exposée aux catastrophes naturelles
qu'il s'agisse d'inondations ou
d'ouragans par exemple et puis il ya les
petits territoires insulaires qui sont
évidemment menacer directement par la
hausse du niveau des mers mais aussi par
des ouragans
[Musique]
on estime qu environ 20 millions de
personnes sont déplacées chaque année
par des catastrophes naturelles
pour donner un ordre de grandeur c'est
environ deux à trois fois plus de gens
que de personnes déplacées par des
conflits et des violences
barise et puis à ce chiffre il faut
évidemment ajouter tous ceux qui sont
déplacées par les impacts plus lent des
plus progressif du changement thématique
là évidemment ils sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à compter notamment parce
qu'ils migrent souvent sur le faible
distance et donc échappe à tout contact
statistiques on considère qu'elles
migrent généralement sur de courtes
distances
généralement les gens ne cherchent pas
forcément à quitter leur pays
il cherche simplement à se mettre à
l'abri à une distance relativement
faible de leur lieu de vie habituel et
parfois c'est les places dans des
situations de vulnérabilité ils sont à
nouveau exposé à d'autres impacts du
changement climatique
et puis lorsque les impacts du
changement climatique se mêle à d'autres
facteurs notamment des facteurs
économiques ou politiques
alors là on a davantage de migrations
internationales
devant la gravité de la situation des
organisations humanitaires lancent un
appel à la communauté internationale
[Musique]
en réalité il y à toute une série de
réponses que les gouvernements peuvent
déployer d'abord dans certains cas elle
peut être paradoxalement il y as intérêt
à encourager ces migrations parce que
c'est une façon pour les gens de se
mettre à l'abri
il faut également mieux protéger les
droits de ceux qui sont déplacés et
notamment ceux qui sont déplacés à
travers une frontière internationale
tout l'enjeu de nos politiques c'est de
faire en sorte que la migration soit un
choix décidé en conscience par les
populations plutôt qu'une contrainte
et puis il ya toute une série de mesures
locales qui peuvent être faites de
manière à ce que les gens aient
davantage accès à l'information
climatique et plus prendre la décision
de migrer ou de rester en fonction de
leurs caractéristiques personnelles
et puis bien entendu ça ne remplacera
pas l'évidente nécessité de réduire
davantage nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et de nous adapter aux impacts
du changement climatique
mais comme je le disais dans certains
cas la migration en elle même peut être
une solution d'adaptation
[Musique]
il faut se rappeler que l'homme est une
espèce migratoire par définition bien
entendu le changement climatique va
amplifier cela mais il faut bien avoir
conscience que la distribution
géographique de la population la surface
de la planète s'est toujours fait en
fonction de facteurs environnementaux et
que donc le changement climatique va
aussi amener d'une certaine manière
une autre distribution une
redistribution de la population à
l'échelle de la planète
parfois dans la manière dont on présente
ce sujet notamment dans les médias on
évoque une sorte de crise migratoire du
futur comme une sorte de nouvelle vague
migratoire
je pense qu'il faut être conscient que
c'est déjà une réalité
aujourd'hui il faut voir ce que l'on
peut faire aujourd'hui sur le terrain
avec la société civile et avec les
gouvernements pour essayer d'organiser
au mieux ces migrations
parce qu'effectivement nous sommes à
l'aube d'un changement important d'une
redistribution de la population à
l'échelle de la planète est le grand
enjeu
cela va être de conserver la planète
habitable pour tous et pour tout et
particulièrement pour les populations
les plus vulnérables
c'est sans doute le grand enjeu du 21e
siècle la question de l'habitabilité
où allons-nous pouvoir habiter sur cette
planète
[Musique]